>> IT'S AN EASY EXCUSE TO BLAME
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IS WHAT HE PROMISED THAT HE
WOULD HURT THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
THOSE IMAGES THAT SHOCK US AND
SHOCK ANYBODY WITH DECENT
HUMANITY, IT'S THE ROMAN
COLISEUMS.
>> AS WE SPEAK, THEY'RE
EXPECTING MOTHERS, NURSING MOMS,
ELDERLY FOLK, BEING HELD IN
DETENTION UNNECESSARILY DOING
PERMANENT DAMAGE TO CHILDREN.
DONALD TRUMP'S OWN
ADMINISTRATION REPORT ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE TERM NENT
DAMAGE.
>> HE'S TRYING TO TERRORIZE THE
FAMILIES.
HE WANTS TO INTIMIDATE FAMILIES
AND TO CHILL THEM FROM
PARTICIPATING IN AMERICAN LIFE.
HE HAS TO CREATE CHAOS, CREATE A
PROBLEM AND TRY TO BOO THE HERO
THAT SOMEHOW THAT SOLVES IT.
>> MANY DEMOCRATS ARE
EXPERIENCING A DRAMATIC SHIFT IN
THEIR THINKING ON THE ISSUE.
ACCORDING TO A NEW POLL IN
JANUARY, ONLY 23% SAID THERE WAS
A CRISIS.
NOW IT'S 70%.
AN ASTONISHING 40 POINT SHIFT.
TO THINK, MONTHS AGO THEY MOCKED
TRUMP FOR CALLING THE SITUATION
AT THE BORDER A CRISIS.
>> THIS PRESIDENT JUST USED THE
BACKDROP OF THE OVAL OFFICE TO
MANUFACTURE A CRISIS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MUST STOP
HOLDING AMERICAN PEOPLE HOSTAGE.
MUST STOP MANUFACTURING A
CRISIS.
>> THE CRISIS ON THE BORDER IS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
>> THEY ARE CALLING IT A
>> THIS SO-CALLED CRISIS AT THE
BORDER IS FAKE.
>> THIS IS A CRISIS OF HIS OWN
MAKING BECAUSE IT WAS A CAMPAIGN
PLEDGE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WE DON'T NEED
TO CREATE ARTIFICIAL CRISES.
WE HAVE ENOUGH REAL CRISES.
>> TONIGHT THE PRESIDENT TRIES
TO SELL A CRISIS THAT THE FACTS
TELL US DO NOT EXIST.
>> ALL OF THIS, THIS WHOLE MESS,
IS MANUFACTURED.
IT'S A MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
A NONCRISIS AT THE BORDER THAT
IS REALLY NOT FOOLING ANYBODY.
>> THIS SHUT DOWN THAT HE CAUSED
BY CREATING A PHONY CRISIS
ACTUALLY DID CAUSE ONE DANGER
AFTER ANOTHER.
>> NO SIGN OF THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, IT'S PRETTY
TRANQUIL DOWN HERE.
>> FAKE, MANUFACTURED,
ARTIFICIAL.
ONLY REASON THE DEMOCRATS THINK
IT'S A CRISIS NOW, JESSE, IS
BECAUSE THEY FIGURED OUT HOW TO
BENEFIT POLITICALLY FROM IT.
>> I WANT TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH JUAN ABOUT THIS TO SEE HIS
THINKING.
I NEED TO KNOW.
WHAT IS THE PLAN?
WE'RE GOING TO FORGET ABOUT THE
FACT THAT, YOU KNOW, IT BECAME A
CRISIS AFTER SIX MONTHS.
FORGET ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
WARNED THIS WOULD HAPPEN, THAT
WE COULDN'T HANDLE THIS AMOUNT
OF ILLEGAL ALIEN FAMILIES, THAT
THESE ARE REGARD AMOUNTS OF
FAMILIES COMING IN AND WE DON'T
HAVE THE FACILITIES TO HANDLE
IT.
IF AN ADULT MALE FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA COMES TO THE COUNTRY
WITH A MINOR AND SEE A BORDER
PATROL AGENT AND WALK UP, WHAT
IS THE PLAN TO TEAL WITH THAT?
>> AT THE MOMENT --
>> WHAT IS YOUR PLAN?
>> I THOUGHT --
>> WHAT IS THE PLAN.
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN TO DEAL WITH
IT.
HOW DO YOU HANDLE IT?
>> IF SOMEONE IS AT A PORT --
>> I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT.
ACROSS THE RIO GRANDE.
THEY ENTER WITH A MINOR --
>> IF THEY'RE APPLYING FOR
ASYLUM, THEY SAY YOU'RE ALLOWED
TO APPLY.
>> SO YOU DON'T KNOW WHO THEY
ARE.
THEY DON'T HAVE IDs.
YOU TONIGHT KNOW IF THEY'RE
RELATED.
HOW DO YOU KNOW THEY'RE RELATED?
>> I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT.
WHAT YOU DO IS IF YOU'RE THE
BORDER PATROL OFFICER, YOU ASK
QUESTIONS AND ALSO --
>> WHERE DO YOU ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
YOU SIT AND TALK --
>> IN THE MIDDLE OF THE HOT
DESERT?
>> NO.
>> SO YOU BELIEVE WE TAKE THEM
TO A FACILITY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> YOU DON'T ASK THEM QUESTIONS
TOGETHER.
YOU HAVE TO SEPARATE THEM TO
MAKE SURE THEIR STORIES A
STRAIGHT.
SO YOU BRIEFLY SEPARATE THEM AND
HOLD THEM IN A FACILITY.
ONCE YOU ASK THEM QUESTIONS AND
YOU THINK YOU CAN ASCERTAIN
ANYTHING, WHAT DO YOU DO WITH
THEM NEXT?
>> IF THEY'RE A FAMILY, THEN YOU
HAVE TO -- IF THEY APPLIED FOR
ASYLUM.
>> WHAT IS THE PROCESS?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THEM?
WHAT DO YOU PHYSICALLY DO WITH
THEM?
>> AT THE MOMENTS WE DETAIN
PEOPLE FOR A TIME AND NINE WE
LET THEM GO.
>> OKAY.
SO YOU LET THEM GO.
TO THE INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY.
>> NO.
PEOPLE COME BACK FOR THOSE --
>> 7%.
>> SO YOU LET'S THEM TALK TO THE
AGENTS AND RELEASE THEM AND WAIT
FOR A HEARING.
>> CORRECT.
>> THAT'S WHAT TRUMP IS DOING.
THAT'S EXACT WILL TRUMP IS
DOING.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> YES, IT IS.
>> THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING AND YOU'RE CALLING HIM THE
SCOUNDREL, THIS BIGOT AND YOU
AGREED WITH THE WHOLE PROCESS.
>> YOU MISSED A LOT OF NEWS.
>> IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> BECAUSE TRUMP HAS NOW LIMITED
APPLICATIONS FOR ASYLUM.
TOLD PEOPLE TO WAIT IN MEXICO.
YOU MUST HAVE MISSED A MONTHS OF
MONTH.
>> JUAN, YOU JUST AGREED WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
HIS EXACT POLICY.
>> LET ME SAY THIS.
ONE, TRUMP EXACERBATED A
DIFFICULT SITUATION.
THERE WAS NEVER AN INVASION BY
ANY MILITARY FORCE COMING ACROSS
THAT BOARDER.
NOW IT'S A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
THAT'S WHY THE NUMBERS HAVE GONE
UP.
WE'VE SEEN THE PICTURES.
YOU SAW THE PICTURE OF THE MAN
THAT DIED WITH HIS DAUGHTER.
>> I THINK NANCY PELOSI GOT ON
THE HORN AND SENT OUT A TALKING
POINTS MEMO TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE MEDIA THAT CALLED IT FAKE
AND MANUFACTURED AND SAID YOU
IDIOTS, WE NEED --
>> THAT'S DIFFERENT --
>> WHY DID THEY CHANGE THEIR
TUNE SO RAPIDLY?
>> BECAUSE THEY REALIZED THAT
THEY WERE DISGUSTING HYPOCRITES.
I REMEMBER HOW THIS STARTED.
WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS SHOW.
IT BEGAN WITH THE EXCITEMENT OF
CARAVANS WITH THE ACTIVISTS
PUSH.
TO ENCOURAGE THE USE 0 CHILDREN
AS PROPS IN A STRATEGY TO
OVERRUN A SYSTEM THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY RUN BY OBAMA.
ALL OF THOSE PICTURES OF KIDS IN
CAGES WERE FROM OBAMA'S TIME.
NEVER MINDS.
BUT PEOPLE DID DIE DURING THAT.
WHILE THEY DIED, ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE SAID THERE WAS NO CRISIS.
SO I DON'T -- WHEN THEY TALKED
ABOUT THE SUFFERING AND THE
DRAWNING THAT HAPPENED NOW, THAT
MAKES ME SICK BECAUSE THOSE
PEOPLE WERE LAUGHING WHEN PEOPLE
WERE TALKING ABOUT CRISIS.
THEY LOST THEIR SEAT AT THE
TABLE.
>> LITERALLY LAUGHING.
>> LOOK, YOU HAVE A SITUATION
HERE WHERE THEY HAVE KNOWN WHAT
THE SITUATION IS.
IT'S NOT AS THOUGH ANYBODY JUST
BECAME AWARE OF IT.
THE REASON THE PRESIDENT WAS
ELECTED IS BECAUSE AMERICANS
RECOGNIZE THE PROBLEM.
WE CARED ABOUT IT BECAUSE
SPECIFICALLY THAT DAD AND THAT
LITTLE GIRL THAT DIED HAS BEEN
ENCOURAGED TO COME.
>> EXACTLY.
>> BECAUSE OF THE RHETORIC THAT
WE HEAR ABOUT FREE HEALTHCARE,
SANCTUARY CITIES.
MAYBE THEY WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
SAFER AT HOME BUT THE MOVE
MOVING THROUGH BECAUSE OF THE
ENCOURAGEMENT OF LITERAL
RHETORIC, WHAT GAVIN NEWSOME IS
SAYING, OBAMA WAS SAYING AT THE
TIME, IS HAVING THEM UNDERTAKE
THESE ADVENTURES THAT END UP
BEING VERY DANGEROUS.
NOW WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE
BEING -- LITTLE KIDS ARE BEING
RENTED OUT ON THE SOUTHERN SIDE
OF THE BORDER FOR PEOPLE TO
BRING THEM OVER.
IT FACILITATES SEX TRAFFICKING
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND PAIN
AND SUFFERING.
ALL OF THIS RHETORIC JUST
BECAUSE OF THE POLITICS OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE OPPOSED TO.
THEY WILL BE ABANDONED BY A
SYSTEM THAT WILL COLLAPSE LIKE
THE ONE THEY'RE FLEEING FROM.
>> AND THEY'RE TRYING TO LEAVE A
DIFFICULT SITUATION --
>> AND A DEAD DAD AND DEAD